ce mardi 15 juin séjour de match à saint
germes en les les bars et restaurants
sont bien remplies pour voir l'entrée en
lice de la france face à l'allemagne à
l'euro après la traditionnelle
marseillaise l'ambiance monte d'un cran
quand la france marque le premier but de
la partie à la 20e minute suite à une
erreur du défenseur allemand mats
hummels le score ne changera plus
jusqu'à la pause au plus grand plaisir
des supporters vient les blancs bien
joué il a été brûlé vif comme aiment à
but contre leur camp mais plutôt bien la
france avant je pense que la deuxième mi
temps ça ira beaucoup mieux pour nous
et puis les ça va démarrer beaucoup
mieux 3 0 pour la france
moi je dis 3 0 tous à distance par ses
supporters divino installée à 700
kilomètres du stade de munich les bleus
pense doubler la mise en seconde période
mais kylie ann m bape et plus karim
benzema voit leur but refusé pour hors
jeu
le coup de sifflet final libère
finalement les fans victoire 1 0
on a eu un gros match et qu'il de france
et aussi l'allemagne très gros match
mais vive la france continue comme ça on
va on va y aller en droit dedans
prochain match pour les bleus ce samedi
19 juin contre la hongrie une nouvelle
occasion pour ses fans libinois de
s'enflammer
à l'honneur